hey youtubers is Charlie huge news the
BBC just released the night of the
doctor the mini episode chronicling how
Paul McGann turned into John Hurt the
dark doctor or the warrior as he calls
himself
I know originally I said I was gonna
post my top 5 Doctor Who villains but
this is just so much cooler right now
we'll do a breakdown first and I've also
got details on the 50th anniversary
livestream that we're doing with the BBC
America first I want to say thank you to
BBC America for sending me this giant
TARDIS I had a little bobble head that I
used to put in some of my videos but I
have been upgraded so high fives now to
business so the night of the doctor
Chronicles the regeneration of Paul
McGann into John Hurt originally we'd
heard that Paul McGann was going to be
part of the 50th anniversary in many
episode content but when I posted that
video it was so long ago and we hadn't
received any confirmation between then
and now so it was kind of a pipe dream
and I thought it was just a rumor
the doctors whoops in to save a woman
from a gunship crashing into the planet
Karn he doesn't know her but he is
wearing a costumes it's really
reminiscent of the TV movie as well as
the Big Finish stuff that he's been
doing recently she does recognize the
TARDIS and you do get a sense for how
the rest of the universe views the Time
Lords in this moment they basically hate
them just as much as they hate the
Daleks just because they're basically
destroying everything in their war the
doctor does say that he is a lover not a
fighter but she doesn't care and they
end up crashing anyway we find out The
Sisterhood of Karn knew that this was
all probably going to happen and that he
was going to be the one to end the time
war we can talk about why that is in the
comments below just because Karn has a
big history in the Doctor Who universe
you're not familiar with The Sisterhood
they're the keepers of the sacred flame
which is used to make the elixir of life
which is what's in those goblets that
the women are holding in this episode
it's basically used during difficult
regeneration the interesting thing here
is that they present him with all the
colors of the rainbow he can be any kind
of doctor he wants to be but he chooses
to be a warrior because the universe has
no use for a doctor right now so this is
where we get confirmation that Paul
McGann regenerates into John Hurt I
think there were a lot of theories about
where John Hurt fell in the Doctor Who
timeline but I think we'd always kind of
sense that he was the eight-point-five
doctor he is part of the Doctor Who
lineage because he was born from a
regeneration he just did not call
himself the doctor just because I think
the doctor is kind of a symbol of
universal peace or chaos depending on
how you look at it so what did I think
of the episode
it was fantastic of course giant a I
actually watched it about four times to
make sure I wasn't missing anything it's
it an amazing job of explaining what's
going on in the 50th anniversary episode
that they're in the middle of the time
war and why he became the John Hurt
doctor I think that was really the main
purpose of the mini episode to explain
why the John Hurt doctor was born I also
really love the moment where he
basically said goodbye to all of his
friends and previous companions he's
basically saying that I have something
really awful that I have to do please
forgive me the episode also looks
amazing visually too you can't really
tell it apart from any of the other
episodes the quality is so good the
plant he's on is obviously the same
planet you see John Hurt on in the 50th
anniversary trailer so obviously part of
the 50th anniversary episode will take
place on Karn I thought it was
interesting though that even though he
died in the crash with the gunship The
Sisterhood brought him back to life for
four minutes only just perform in its
time enough to choose a new flavor of
doctor but for those of you this on my
previous video I said that jenna-louise
Coleman basically told us that we would
see a regeneration in the 50th
anniversary episode obviously that is
not going to be this regeneration so
that means that we will probably see
John Hurt regenerate into Christopher
Eccleston I know he's technically
physically not in the 50th anniversary
episode but you know how they showed
John Hurt basically in a reflection they
can use Christopher Eccleston zhh
likeness as obviously they have to
chronicle the time between the end of
the time war and the time where the
doctor met Rose Tyler but let me know
what are your reactions to the night of
the doctor and seeing this regeneration
it's amazing to see Paul McGann as
Doctor Who in an official Doctor Who
production is so great and if you've
never seen Paul McGann's doctor before
and you're like a Matt Smith David
Tennant fan who hasn't seen a lot of
classic who let me know if you
understand what's going on in the story
right now because we can talk about it
in the comments so like I said I'll be
doing tons more Doctor Who videos for
the 50th anniversary I'll be doing a
Doctor Who giveaway I'll be giving away
Doctor Who 50th anniversary DVDs
starting tomorrow so look for that video
tomorrow morning big thank you to
Nerdist and BBC America for sending me
the giant TARDIS here you can also look
forward to the livestream we'll be doing
on November 23rd before the 50th
anniversary episode that will start at
2:20 p.m. Eastern Time the 50th
anniversary will air at 2:50 p.m.
Eastern Time I'll be sure to post a link
to the live stream and all my videos in
the description as well as in the
comments whenever that happens if you
have any questions about the 50th
anniversary what's happening or the
content I'm doing be sure to write it in
the comments right now click here to
watch all my other special 50th
anniversary videos and click here to
learn all about Peter Capaldi's new
Doctor is so much for watching see you
guys tonight high five
you